actually the line that I was going to
quote was not that line it was
excuse my language here fix your
before something you waste someone it's
time something like that which I loved
tumbling but he can be applied to many
things not just a relationship holy and
so that's where I was kind of going with
that it's funny you say that because
that's sort of my excuse on why I don't
date right now is not other people it's
me fixing and since we're working wasn't
we're now speaking in French me fixing
my own before I just unloaded on
somebody else cuz I you know it's sort
of one of those things where you want to
be able as it does apply to
relationships you want to be able to
give someone your all you want to give
them your time and attention when you're
after a pursuit like this you know your
time and attention is hard to come by
very true and that's why I'm saying it
is a lonely journey when you focus
whether it's an entrepreneur we've
talked to people that are working in
tact or different things and it is a
lonely thing because you people end up
falling away because you're always busy
trying to do stuff and it's not because
maybe they're mad at you but you just
isolate yourself but the best example
are people that are always surrounded by
people they are so afraid to face
themselves and that's the whole point
one that's that's why I think is the
most graphic what is the word gratifying
gratifying
that when you have that you can totally
get everything and that is on your way
and just break through them but as soon
as you are afraid to face yourself to
face your demon there's no way you're
gonna be able to make it I think in this
business you're just gonna be pushed
left and right and you're going to be so
scared and screaming oh I want to quit
where's my plane being so right and any
key deploy be applied to filmmaking as
well so fixing or whatever your stuff
before you so it sounds like yeah being
focused this doesn't mean thing what's
all and it's also that I mean it's
acting sort of beautiful in the sense
that any problems that you have in your
personal life will manifest in your work
and and those kind of the weakness is
the proclivities all those things they
show up in the work and so the work
becomes sort of the the ground with
which you address these things within
yourself and
the takeaway is pretty remarkable if
you're really putting yourself into into
the work that you're doing the amount
that you can learn about the way that
you approach problems or the way that
you react in situations I mean I know I
was surprised over the course of the
film especially considering going back
to the audition with the vulnerability
I mean how easy it was to me but by the
end to just fly off the handle dallisa
liked it I mean it was cathartic in a
way but it also surprised me and and it
was something that you know since then
I've really gotten to know intimately
that side of myself aside that maybe I
denied before I met Pascale and and
started doing and ended this film
they say that therapists should also be
in therapy do you think that that
actress should be in therapy because
there are things that that maybe are
blind you know they say we have this
like shadow stuff that we don't see sure
but I think acting or doing a film like
even for him when it was I think he was
going through something when we did the
film and a lot of thing and but he
brought that and it worked and sometimes
it didn't work and I have to refocus him
a little bit but when some time he
wasn't this kind of dark zone you just
fed from it and it worked so I think
screw therapy just you know acting a
film or something yeah I only laughed at
the therapy line only because I feel
like maybe actors shouldn't be in
therapy only because I feel like the
greatest gift that you can give
audiences is that vulnerable messy
chaotic ugly side of yourself and you
want to discover yourself take stuff to
things and if you know all the answer
right away there's nothing left to be
discovered I don't even know if there is
such a thing as a well-balanced actor or
artist maybe in general so if you're one
of these keep calm and carry on type
people then that's not really gonna
translate I mean I mean if it works and
God bless you maybe I mean I'm sure that
there were people that can prove me
wrong on that and and if so like caps
off to you but I'd say for everybody
else let your freak flag fly
you